تساقط كثيف للثلوج في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف في الوقت الذي ما زال 25 بالمئه من
سكان المدينه دون كهرباء وتعمل سلطات
المدينه لاستعاده التيار واستقرار جدول
القطع الكهربائي على ان لا يتجاوز عدد
ساعات الانقطاع خمسه ساعات في اليوم همم
كل شيء جيد لقد اسعدنا خيرسون وسنستعيد
جولي بولو محافظه تاريخ
وكل شيء سيكون بخير فهذه اوكرانيا
باي حال من الاحوال سوف نتعامل مع كل
الظروف ولن ننكسر
يعملون بالفعل على ازاله الثلوج من
الطرقات في الوقت الحالي تعمل مئه وسته
وعشرون وحده من المعدات واكثر من 300
متخصصه من هيئه صيانه الطرق ويشاركه في
الحمله اكثر من 1000 عامل من الشركات
متعاقده مع الدوله
مدير عام شيخ شنيا
انا اعمل عليه ازاله الثلوج الثلج يتساقط
بطبيعه الحال في هذا التوقيت ونحن نعمل
على ازالتها ونظافه الشوارع
وفقا للتوقعات ستزداد كثافه تساقط الثلوج
والصقيع في المدينه كما ستنخفض درجه
الحراره الى درجتين مئويتين تنصرف خلال
انهار وسالب 50 درجات مئويه في الليل لذلك
تحث السلطات المواطنين على الامتناع عن
السفر في سياراتهم الخاصه كما يطلب من
السائقين توخي الحذر على الطريق واذا امكن
عدم قياده السياره اثناء تساقط الثلوج اذا
فعادل العربي العربيه كيف